now I I want to pull up this story
because I'll tell you this with the
Zuckerberg thing the the one I I I agree
with you uh we need to win the culture
war and I will say this one of the
reasons I probably just outright vote
for Renaissance is that he went after
big Tech in any way we have this story
if you head over to Instagram and take a
look at Mr Luke we are change that's his
uh his his Instagram handle is at Luke
we are change if you try to follow him
and please do you may be greeted with
this message it says are you sure you
want to follow Luke we are change this
account has repeatedly posted false
information that was reviewed by
independent fact Checkers or went
against our community guidelines I
unfollowed Luke and followed him back
and I got that message yeah prove it you
sobs what fake news I I post highly
sophisticated intelligent
thought-provoking memes with like 3D 4D
level chess I mean can can you pull up
my my uh just some of the things I post
on there especially the George George W
bush one because because if they go
after that one they're admitting that
they're a part of wrong think uh be
because the Pfizer one up there again
all I post right all I post is it's like
segments from here my shirts and memes I
I love to yeah one to to post memes
about you know curious things that make
people critically think about the issues
it's not even facts yeah well that's a
shirt no fake news that's a real shirt
and and I have one one shirt that's
censored and it's scribbled that says
tax this D and I have another shirt
that's not censored and you could get
that on the bus the bus political
shows.com but I can't say it here but I
mean look what I post I I post stuff
like Joe Biden leaving office in 2024.
how can you fact check that how can you
fact do you have a magic like time
machine that you could say oh he's
definitely lying this needs to be fact
checked number one what's the fact
checks tell me tell me what what I got
wrong through these banjo Biden
here we go it is an old man in front of
a burning car and it is not Joe how do
you know Joe Biden's not gonna look like
that in in three years I get it how I
get it so so so so so again and then and
another thing who's fact checking me let
you know let's let's call it spade a
spade here but put out your name but
what organization who's behind it and
and what exactly do you have problems
with with posts like this tell me right
now and they won't we had we had James
o'keefeon and we were talking about
Stanford put out a a study claiming that
James O'Keefe me Tim Poole Sydney Powell
and Linwood and some other people were
like the biggest purveyors of voter
misinformation or whatever and um and
and I'm like what did James tweet about
anything he he like he posts Veritas
stories where it's they literally have
undercover things on other people and
what do I buy post on Twitter like I
post I think I posted a picture of a
hairless rabbit once I post stories all
of its News Guard certified and the best
part is
Trump supporters got extremely mad at me
for saying there was no widespread voter
fraud the entire time I've been saying
that I even said it to Steve Bannon when
he came on the show I was like Ben I
disagree I think we look at that story
from Mark Zuckerberg you take a look at
the laws being changed I think that this
is you know it's pulling people off off
base because the Democrats have
excellent ground game and they put out
fake news for some reason and then of
course people are like well if Stanford
said it must be true when they put it on
Wikipedia and then it becomes fast or
CNN telling everyone that it's you know
horse dewormer uh there's so many lies
by the mainstream media and you know
Anderson Cooper all these other you know
professional fake news spreaders all
these professional propagandists they
get to do whatever they want on these
big Tech social media companies they you
know but also I was criticizing
Instagram and Facebook really hard over
the mental health issues a couple days
ago uh specifically also on this show
and I was making my own videos about
this on my own YouTube channel I was
going after them hard detailing the the
site psychological experiments that they
done on unsuspecting users so so this
seems more vindictive than anything else
because you look at the post I make
they're silly they're ridiculous they're
they're over the top I I you know I told
people I don't even care I'm just gonna
post ridiculous stuff on Instagram if it
gets taken down and gets taken down and
a couple couple days ago I I attempt
laughing
yeah it's real the
for that
for those that are listening it says NPR
accuses Dave Chappelle of using white
privilege and then below it is Dave
Chappelle as Clayton Bixby the black
white supremacist and it says good for
nothing tricksters he's blind in that
bottom picture he doesn't realize well
this is from his own skit where he was
pretending to be a black KKK member uh
and a racist against black people who
was black himself but didn't know
because he was blind and the KKK had him
around and he was good friends with them
and they were like yeah we're just not
gonna tell him because this is pretty
funny a couple weeks ago I posted on
September 16th hey because something
weird happened I I was I was doing okay
on my Instagram before before I came
here on this show my numbers were Rising
pretty well and I was getting a lot of
interaction I was getting a lot of views
and then out of nowhere it stopped and I
was getting a one tenth of my engagement
and then for for weeks it was the same
one tenth and I'm like What's Happening
here so I put a post hey this is a test
Instagram has been has been limiting our
post to more than 10 percent of our
followers if you see this click like and
tell me that you see this in your
timeline they fact check it they said
this is fake news it's incorrect even
though and the analytics show a nine
tenth drop in audience interaction
suddenly without me changing anything or
changing any way that I post or interact
with audience members so they're even
fact checking saying that it's false
that they're limiting me to my audience
which they clearly are through the
analytics through the numbers uh and
it's this is the world that we're living
in right now where memes like this you
know memes memes then again I'm not
making any stance here I'm not telling
people what to do here I'm just trying
to make people laugh and think a little
bit
um and for them to Target this is
ridiculous and uh absolutely a sham a
huge Injustice and ridiculous to say the
least just as ridiculous as the memes I
mean the George W bush one that I posted
we don't have to show it here but but if
they flag that one that that means that
they're committing wrong think all right
that's how that's that's the level of
sophistication of of me Warfare that we
have going on here that that again is
extremely important I remember first
coming on the show I said memes are
going to be the thing that are going to
change the landscape of our political
dichotomy I I really do truly believe in
them and I think that's why they're
going after satire now which I said you
know they're going to figure out how to
go after satire I think this is the
first step in that direction they've
been they've been doing this that this
is why they had to ban the Donald
because memes
got Trump elected yeah maybe maybe not
like the core of his platform but it
gave him the bump he needed magic man
have you seen that documentary on Meme
magic no it's like a you it's like a
YouTube documentary somebody made but
it's really really interesting how they
go through like the history of Keck and
like the Frog and pepe interesting and
the weird stuff on 4chan and they were
like me magic man but whether or not you
believe in magic when you have people
who have found a way to have fun
and build community and then all of a
sudden everyone's laughing with each
other and sharing jokes
that's going to help that person out
yeah and I'm not even like promoting
anything I'm not even telling people
what to do I'm just saying hey this this
is a stupid ridiculous government policy
let's laugh about it that's it I'm not
even saying do this or get involved or
don't do this I'm not even doing any of
that on Instagram so my response to this
is uh uh you know family-friendly show
uh screw you Instagram uh everyone
follow me at Luke we arcade and uh just
in case they take me down uh go check
out enough of censorship.com which is a
link to my email list which makes me
uncensorable no matter what happens so
that's my response my official statement
to Instagram or anybody asking about
this story that's officially what I got
to say screw you Instagram uh let's make
sure that this policy doesn't work it's
ridiculous and I want to thank the the
people who are sending me this because I
wouldn't have noticed uh you know no one
told me this I never got a warning I
never got a notification they didn't
tell me anything and just sporadically I
just see my viewership go down within
the last few weeks and it's just it's
just weird and strange that we're living
in this world where you know you could
be convicted of wrong think and then
have your actions yeah not even know but
also have your access to people that
you're that are your friends and are
part of your community taken away from
you uh just because some fact Checker
whoever that random mysterious person is
decided that he doesn't like your humor
yeah it's almost like this should be
against the law okay that would be
really what I'm thinking of this is like
them making an editorial claim on your
content be standing behind it like a
platform or like a publisher rather uh
which we I had a long conversation with
Section 230 last night and about editing
section 230 basically fixing it so that
maybe companies that make editorial
claims like this account is responsible
for X then become considered publishing
news but but we don't even have to argue
no hold on it will take it away so like
here's I actually you know there's two
parts of it right there's the making the
weird little editorial claim About You
Luke right which is the most hilarious
thing because it's like it either is
fake or it violates our community
guidelines we're not going to tell you
which one like you know if lawyers would
laugh at that right it's stupid but and
then there's the actual throttling now
if it weren't for the throttling I think
this if anything would make you more
popular because it's such an obviously
ridiculous way to try and indict someone
they've said some things that are false
based on someone saying they were false
we're not going to tell you what was
false who determined it like it would
just it would be BS it's the throttling
that's the problem and so it's like it's
like those Twitter notifications when
they put them on like I don't think
those are a big problem it's the
algorithmic throttling that is is really
wrong and so you know it's hard to say
anything about the you know when they
make these statements they are speaking
right and I I think that they do have a
First Amendment right to speak if they
want to put stuff at the bottom of my
tweets that's their right if they're
they're constraining my ability to reach
my audience then they're censoring and
that's different and I don't think they
have a guaranteed First Amendment right
to censor people does the First
Amendment check out in private companies
like this though so uh the First
Amendment this is actually an
interesting area of the law like the
question is can a state or government
give additional protection First
Amendment rights or additional speech
rights to their citizens on private
platforms right and the answer to that
the the case that's closest is a case
about is called premier shopping center
is it based on a California question
about whether people had the right to
petition in shopping malls basically
like there was a state law in California
that said or a California Supreme Court
decision that said our citizens have the
right to petition in in shopping malls
as a First Amendment right under our
California Constitution
and the shopping mall owners like but
that's a violation of My First Amendment
rights like I don't want to be
Associated I have a freedom of
Association right I don't want to be
associated with uh the this random
petitioner it's also you know free free
speech right I have the right to censor
like Etc and the Supreme Court's like no
no you don't no one's associating you to
speech you have the ability to say what
you want to say
um and as a result your speech rights
aren't implicated so it's perfectly
acceptable for a state to give private
consumers you know private individuals
the right competition on your property I
think you know you're not performing any
editorial function nobody thinks you are
so Facebook and Twitter are in the same
position they're not performing any
equal editorial function they're they
have seven million people I think we
need to uh I mentioned this to James
O'Keefe
on Wikipedia
the article about project Veritas is
just the most insane garbled lies far
right disinformation organization and I
said to him I was like James what does
it say on top of the article it says
from Wikipedia it doesn't say from you
know cow you know finger 93 it doesn't
say it's from you know Ian the cow
finger or 97. it says it's from
Wikipedia and if Wikipedia is taking the
byline on this one aren't they
responsible for that speech presented on
that platform another thing to really
kind of entertain here is one of the
things that made the internet so amazing
so wonderful was the free access to
whoever you wanted to follow you
followed someone you saw their content
it was incredible it was amazing we
don't have that anymore you follow
someone you may see their stuff you may
not see their stuff there's a carefully
curated algorithm that has a long-term
psychological negative effects on the
population that is rising suicide levels
that is rising self-hurt incidences that
is rising levels of depression that is
rising the levels of psychological
disorders and this is because now
they're carefully curating what
information you get to hear and not hear
I mean and and that decision should be
up to a human being saying I want to
follow him I want to I want to see what
he posts if you're not following them
you shouldn't be send stuff that that
you don't want to see but right now if
you look at Instagram a lot of the stuff
is forced on your news feed you look at
uh the Facebook news feed you look at
Twitter Instagram now says like these
three posts are recent after that I'm
scrolling and it's random and I'm like
wait I don't follow these people yeah
and then you gotta click see older posts
to actually get the people you follow
now so this is Sinister on so many
different levels because people actively
want to follow me want to find my
content they're denied that by using
this platform so that's another level of
interacting of of intervening in
something that was free was awesome gave
people what they wanted because people
were sick sick of being lectured to
people are sick of me being lied to
people were sick of just being force-fed
nonsense now we're back to the day and
age where they're force fed nonsense
every single day while restricting the
small and independent voices that made
them as popular as they are regarding
the uh the shopping mall metaphor if
with the shopping will then be allowed
to put up a sign like the petitioners
over there the shop milk have a sign
says petitioners that way lying about it
could they do that and could they have a
sign that said liar pointing at the
petitioners the latter sure right like
that that's a speech right you know like
again either on their own property they
have the right to speak and say these
people are lunatics who are going to
hell who knows right
um and then on the but on the the first
one decept like deceiving then that
might be thwarting the underlying right
to speak which is a little bit so you
could argue that changing the algorithm
without their knowledge is a form of
Deceit right I think I think that you
could I think that it it poses a very
interesting question about whether or
not a state could itself have imposed
kind of regulations on the algorithm
it's it's trickier because it gets
that's a little closer speech like
you're forcing them to organize the
information that appears in the feed in
a certain way what would be nice is if
you could force them to show at least
how they're organizing it by displaying
the algorithmic code sure is is there an
argument to make here about the
manipulation of the news feed that is
creating self-harm and psychological
disorders because there are medical
studies that are showing that you know
if you show certain images you do have a
certain psychological effect on a human
being and I think there's a lot of
correlation with social media use and
you know depression suicide everything
that I talked about before is there even
some kind of room in court to maneuver
to say this social media caused actual
real life harm well I mean you have that
you you can't one there's you can't
prohibit you can't force people to speak
right that's part part of the first
amendment is that you don't have the you
don't have you can't force people that's
compelled speech that's also a first
member violation so that's part one
um part two is that you know there are
specific categories of the law that are
where speech is unlawful defamation
right yeah
um so is this considered defamation
um what is is what considered definition
them saying I spread fake news uh not
any examples without any I mean it's it
has to be provably false right and and
you have to prove under current law you
have to prove actual malice right which
means that they're knowingly lying I
would love a jury to see my memes I
would love it that's actually like but
then they say it might violate our
community guidelines wish Community
guidelines well we you know they they
get then they get the entire they can
look at their entire terms of service
and be like aha this was inflammatory
and I'm sure they would say that wasn't
actually Joe Biden I mean
how do you know look there's not 2024.
look at because the jury will agree and
be like yeah that's not Joe Biden and
then they'll say CR our statement was
true he said it was Joe Biden the the
whether or not someone understands the
joke or not is not on you know us when
we say some people won't get it so like
here's the thing like that the reason
that statement that they preview you
they say like you've posted fake news or
false news as determined by an
independent fact Checkers and and or you
violated Community guidelines not
specifying how it's fake what it is or
what news that's lawyered right because
that's vague it is a very very vague
criticism it literally could go either
way it doesn't even actually accuse you
necessarily of having put out anything
fake so
um as a result like when you make a
really vague lawyered statement like
that it's almost impossible to prove
falsity okay and so that's that would
which is a necessary element of any
definition thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time